Привіт! Мене звати Віктор Мельников,
я викладач математики в школі «Майбутні».
Сьогодні у нас заняття для 9 класу
за темою: «Задачі, пов’язані з
геометричною прогресією»
Раніше ми з вами вивчали - що таке
геометрична прогресія.
Геометрична прогресія - це послідовність,
в якій кожний наступний член - попередній,
помножений на якесь число.
Це число називається знаменник і
позначається літерою q.
Ми вивчили низку формул.
Наприклад те, що наступний член - це
попередній помножений на q.
Формулу n-го члена.
Щоб знайти n-ий член, треба перший член
помножити знаменник в степені n-1.
І також характеристичну властивість
геометричної прогресії.
Це те, що член геометричної прогресії в
квадраті дорівнює добутку своїх сусідів.
Сьогодні ми з вами будемо розв’язувати
задачі,
що пов’язані з геометричною прогресією
і будемо практикуватися.
Можете взяти аркуш і розв’язувати
паралельно.
Так, давайте практикуватися і перейдемо
до першої задачі.
Давайте запишемо цю умову.
Щоб знайти знаменник, нам треба наступний
член поділити на попередній.
Тобто, (1/36):(1/216).
Поділити, помножити, перегортаємо дріб
і скорочуємо.
Можна скоротити одразу на 36
і отримаємо 6.
Отже, знаменник дорівнює 6.
П’ятий член можна знайти використовуючи
формулу n-го члена геометричної прогресії.
Нагадаємо.
Перший член помножити на знаменник
в степені 5-1, на одиничку менше.
І підставляємо.
Рахувати це дуже довго, тому можна
згадати, що 216 - це 6 в кубі і скоротити,
і вийде, що це просто 6.
Отже, 5-й член геометричної прогресії 6.
Добре, давайте йти далі.
Наступна задача.
Давайте подумаємо.
Отже, перша думка, яка може промайнути:
що, якщо кожного разу більше й більше,
то площа буде так само прогресувати?
Тобто, якщо спочатку площа = 6, то потім
буде вдвічі більша = 12, потім = 24 і т.д.
І так можна порахувати до четвертого,
тобто 24*2=48.
Але це помилка.
Давайте розберемось чому.
Розглянемо ось такий маленький квадратик
і нехай у нього сторони будуть один.
Якщо ми збільшимо наш квадратик вдвічі,
то ми бачимо,
що в цей новий квадратик поміститься
чотири ось таких.
Площа вже тут буде 4 см квадратних.
Чому ж так відбувається?
Кожна сторона помножилась вдвічі,
а площа вдвічі не помножилась,
вона стала набагато більшою.
Справа в тому, що, якщо тут якась
сторона х, то тут уже буде 2х.
І якщо тут була площа х^2,
то коли сторони будуть 2х, то площа=4х^2.
Тобто взагалі площа якихось фігур,
якщо вони подібні і є якийсь коефіцієнт,
на який множаться всі сторони, то ця площа
буде, це число - в квадраті разів більше.
Тобто якщо у нас тут була площа 6
і сторона збільшилась вдвічі,
то наступна площа буде не вдвічі більше,
а в чотири рази більше.
Тобто 6*4=24, а не 12 і т. д.
Тобто, насправді, це геометрична прогресія
з першим числом 6,
перший член - це площа маленького, а q,
знаменник, у нас буде не 2, а 4.
Тому що у нас йде мова про площу,
а не про сторони.
І нам треба знайти 4-й член.
b4 = b1*q^3,
тобто 6*4^3.
4 в кубі = 64,
6*64=384
Добре, давайте подивимось
на наступну задачу.
Давайте спочатку запишемо, що три числа
утворюють арифметичну прогресію.
Як це можна зробити?
От у нас є якийсь перший
член арифметичної прогресії а1,
тоді наступний а1+d і далі це а1+2d.
Тобто це три окремих числа,
які утворюють арифметичну прогресію:
кожний наступний
більший на число d.
До цих чисел ми додали 2, 3, 9
і попередня умова,
що їх сума дорівнює 21.
Тоді числа а1+2; а1+d+3; а1+2d+9 — це
геометрична прогресія.
Ми можемо записати характеристичну
властивість, тобто
що другий член в квадраті
дорівнює добутку першого і третього.
Це ось така система виходить.
Якщо ми так зробимо, в нас з вами вийде:
3а1+3d=21,
а тут вийде якесь дуже некрасиве рівняння,
тому що під квадратами аж три числа
і дуже багато всього множити.
Тому, коли ви обираєте ось такий спосіб
записати арифметичну прогресію,
то у вас відбувається щось
трішки складніше.
Є маленький спосіб, як
можна зробити це легше.
І зараз ми це зробимо.
Щоб зробити задачу, можна ці три числа,
які утворюють арифметичну прогресію,
записати трішки по-іншому.
Ми спочатку запишемо той, що
по середині а2, тоді наступний це а2+d,
а попередній ми можемо записати, як а2-d.
І тоді ці числа утворюють арифметичну
прогресію, додаємо d і отримаємо це і т.д.
Але це значно спрощує розрахунки.
І тоді, це у нас перше число, друге
і третє.
Геометрична прогресія:
до першого ми додаємо 2, до другого
додаємо 3
і до третього додаємо 9.
І запишемо характеристичну властивість.
В чому особливість, чому це краще?
Тому що із першого рівняння, ось тут, коли
ми записали, що ця сума дорівнює 21,
у нас d і (-d) скоротяться,
буде а2+а2 тричі, тобто 3а2=21,
ми одразу можемо зрозуміти,
що другий член дорівнює 21:3, тобто 7.
І тоді просто підставити сюди.
Замість а2 поставити 7.
У нас вийде.
Так набагато швидше розв’язувати.
І тут треба розв’язати квадратне рівняння,
розкриваючи всі дужки і т.д.
Тоді розкриючи дужки, отримаємо таке, далі
будемо розв’язувати квадратне рівняння.
Переносимо все ліворуч.
І далі треба розв’язати це рівняння.
Можна за допомогою теореми Вієта:
добуток (-44), а сума (-b), тобто (-7).
Це наприклад, числа... Увага на дошку
І тоді можна отримати ці два числа.
Середнє у нас завжди буде 7.
Якщо d=-11, то тут буде 7-(-11), тобто 18.
А тут буде 7-11, тобто число (-4).
Так, це перший.
І другий просто підставляємо так само.
Тобто, 7, тут плюс 4 буде 11.
Тут відняти, 7-4=3.
Ці числа утворюють геометричну прогресію,
тут треба відняти 11, тут треба додати 4.
Ну і так далі.
Можна перевірити самостійно,
якщо додати числа 2, 3 і 9,
то має вийти геометрична прогресія.
Ось таким чином.
Подивимось на іншу задачу.
Давайте це запишемо і замість х3, х13
будемо писати за допомогою
формули n-го члена, чому вони дорівнюють.
Тобто, х3 - це перший член помножити
на q в квадраті
І так само тринадцятий, п’ятий,
одинадцятий.
Тобто вийде.
Перемножимо окремо ліву частину,
окремо праву.
Тут вийде х1 в квадраті,
квадрат на 12 степінь, степені додаються.
І тут так само.
Оскільки ліва і права частини у нас рівні,
отже можемо поставити знак рівності
і умова задачі, власне, доведена.
Добре, подивимось на ще одну задачу.
Просто можна зробити.
Щоб отримати наступний, треба попередній
помножити на (-5). 0,2*(-5).
Потім, щоб отримати наступний, попередній
множимо на (-5), тобто (-1)*(-5)=5.
Щоб знайти четвертий, треба ще раз
помножити на (-5) попередній. 5*(-5)=(-25)
І треба знайти чотири, отже, власне
задачу ми виконали.
Подивіться, будь ласка,
на наступну картинку.
Це трикутник Серпинського.
Це такий фрактал, самоподібна фігура,
видана нашим сусідом, польським
математиком Серпинським.
Що цікаво, якщо подивитися на кожний
трикутник, він схожий на фігуру взагалі.
Такі фігури називаються фракталами
і у нас буде задача, пов’язана з цим.
Давайте подивимося як формується цей
трикутник Серпинського.
Увага на дошку.
У нас є червоний заповнений трикутник і
кожного разу ми щось з ним робимо.
Отже, спочатку у нас був суцільно
зафарбований трикутник.
Потім ми взяли точки, які стоять
посередині і вирізали такий трикутничок.
Потім ми проробили цю операцію з кожним
трикутником зафарбованим, який залишився.
І так на кожному кроці.
Ми беремо якийсь трикутник, який
зафарбований
і з нього також вирізаємо посередині
ще один трикутник.
І так робимо нескінченну,
нескінченну кількість разів,
щоб отримати ось такий красивий трикутник.
Так, наша задача.
Треба знайти площу четвертого
за рахунком трикутника,
вірніше не трикутника, а зафарбованої
частини в ньому.
Давайте подивимося, як це можна зробити
і до чого тут геометрична прогресія.
Отже, якщо у нас є ось такий трикутник,
рівносторонній і ми
беремо посередині точки.
Цією лінією ми розрізали наш трикутник
на чотири однакові частини.
Тобто оці трикутники,
вони за площею однакові.
Якщо ми зафарбуємо оці частини,
то яку частину від цього трикутника будуть
мати зафарбовані ці трикутники?
Оскільки у нас три із чотирьох
зафарбовані, то наступного разу,
тобто із цього повністю зафарбованого
сюди,
площа буде становити 3/4 від ось цього.
Потім ми проробимо цю операцію
з кожним трикутником.
І в кожному трикутнику площа теж буде
нова становити 3/4 від попередньої,
тому що ми розділили трикутник на чотири
рівні частини і взяли з нього три.
І так кожного разу.
Насправді, це також геометрична прогресія,
тому що першого разу у нас площа 16.
А другого разу, щоб знайти нову площу,
треба помножити цю площу на 3/4.
Тобто q=3/4.
І якщо нам треба знайти площу четвертого
за рахунком, то ми беремо четвертий член
і за формулою n-го члена знаходимо:
b1*q в кубі.
b1=16 і підставляємо
замість q число (3/4)^3, тобто 27/64
16 і 64 можна скоротити,
і розв'язком отримаємо 27/4
Можна перевести це в інший дріб.
Це буде 6 цілих 3/4, або 6,75.
За бажанням можете порахувати,
якою буде площа в наступному
або також знайти в довідниках інформацію
не про трикутник Серпинського,
а про килим Серпинського і подивись, яка
в ньому закономірність буде виконуватись.
Давайте подивимося на ще типову задачу.
Добре, b1=2, b2=6 і т. д.
Можна знайти q.
Щоб знайти q, треба наступний
член поділити на попередній.
І треба знайти 486.
b з якимось номером n дорівнює 486.
Треба знайти оце n.
Замість bn підставляємо формулу n-го члена
Увага на дошку.
І підставляємо ті значення,
які у нас вже є, тобто b1 і q.
Тобто 2*3 в степені n-1 дорівнює 486.
Скорочуємо.
Отже, в якій степені 3 буде 243?
243=81*3;
81=9*9.
Можна записати, що це 3 в квадраті
помножити на 3 в квадраті і на 3,
тобто 2+2+1, це 3 в п’ятій степені.
Тобто 3 в п’ятій степені буде 243.
Тобто n-1=5. Отже n=6.
Отже, номер числа 486
в цій геометричній прогресії буде 6.
Добре, наступна задача.
Отже, у нас є число 80, а тут число 5 і
між ними ще якихось три числа.
Треба їх знайти.
Якщо це геометрична прогресія,
то кожного разу,
щоб отримати наступний, ми множили
на число q, якийсь знаменник.
Давайте запишемо.
Щоб отримати 5, що треба з 80 зробити?
5 = 80 кілька разів помножити на q.
Отже це q в четвертій степені.
І тоді просто скорочуємо.
В четвертій степені 1/16 може бути
в двох випадках.
Перший це 1/2, другий це (-1/2).
Давайте просто порахуємо,
які це будуть числа.
Якщо q = 1/2, тоді у нас числа...
Увага на дошку.
Якщо (-1/2), то будуть знаки чергуватися.
Ось такі у нас можуть бути числа.
Давайте подивимось на ще одну задачу.
Ми можемо переписати цю умову,
замість кожного b3,b2 і b4 записавши
формулу n-го члена,
записавши таку систему.
Далі нам треба якось виразити, щось ми
можемо винести за дужки, наприклад b1.
І треба розв’язати таку систему.
Як це можна зробити?
Наприклад, виразивши b1 з першого
рівняння, підставивши його сюди.
b1 виражаємо, ділячи праву частину
на 1+q^2
і це не буде новим, тому можна
спокійно ділити.
І підставляємо сюди.
Вийде, що (-5/8) поділивши на 1+q^2
помножити на q і помножити на 1+q^2
дорівнює 5/16
Ви бачите, що ці числа однакові,
можна скоротити просто.
Отже, тут виходить, що (-5/8)*q=5/16.
Знаходимо q.
І якщо q=(-1/2), то можемо знайти b1.
Можна підставити і порахувати.
Перший член - це
(-5/8) поділити на 1+q^2
q^2 = 1/4.
І рахуємо це значення.
(-5/8) ми ділимо на 1+1/4, тобто на 5/4.
Тобто за умовою задачі b1=(-1/2).
Добре, давайте розглянемо наступну задачу
більш теоретичну.
Ми із цієї послідовності, яка у нас є,
вибираємо тільки ті члени,
які мають у нас непарні номери,
тобто лише 1,3,5 і т.д.
Тобто беремо ті числа, які у
нас є з непарними номерами і думаємо -
чи будуть вони геометричною прогресією,
чи ні.
Ми можемо перевірити спочатку на
якомусь прикладі.
І просто перевіримо.
Якщо ми візьмемо перший, третій і п’ятий:
1,4,16.
Чи буде ця прогресія геометричною?
Буде, тому що кожний наступний множиться
на 4, щоб отримати наступний член.
Отже, це геометрична прогресія.
А тепер як це довести
в загальному випадку?
Замість кожного напишемо формулу
n-го члена.
Тобто b1 ; b2=b1*q ; b3=b1*q^2...
І давайте розглянемо лише ті,
які мають непарні номери.
Перший член нової прогресії буде b1.
Наступний - це перший член,
помножений на q в квадраті,
а тоді наступний, давайте подумаємо,
q в квадраті можна записати як...
b1*(q^2)^2
Тобто, якщо ми розглянемо оцей наш новий
знаменник, як q^2, то ми побачимо,
що в нас є перший член, потім перший член
множиться на оце нове число q^2,
потім наступне число множиться на оце нове
число (q^2)^2 і т д.
Тобто виходить, що це теж буде
геометричною прогресією,
тому що кожен наступний член прогресії
множиться на одне і те саме число,
а саме q^2.
Це був перший пункт.
Давайте подумаємо над другим пунктом.
Тепер у нас геометрична прогресія кожного
разу помножилась на 2.
І також можна перевірити,
взяти спочатку одну прогресію,
подивитись, що з неї вийде на практиці.
Візьмемо те саме: 1,2,4,8
і помножимо її на 2.
То буде: 2,4,8,16.
І насправді 2,4,8,16 також
буде прогресією,
тому що, кожний наступний
множиться на 2, щоб отримати.
І в загальному випадку - як це можна
записати.
Давайте, 2b1, а потім замість b2
напишемо b1*q і теж помножимо одразу на 2,
тобто 2b1*q.
Потім b3 так само: b1*q^2,
і за умови ще на 2 множимо і т.д.
І якщо придивитися до
того, що тут написано,
то у нас в новій прогресії
це буде перший член,
це перший член помножити на q,
перший член на q в квадраті і т. д.
Тобто це також геометрична прогресія
з першим членом 2b1 і знаменником q.
Ось так розв’язуються подібні задачі.
Тепер в мене запитання до вас.
Давайте розглянемо.
Якщо перший член дорівнює 3/4, а q=2,
то щоб знайти четвертий член, треба перший
помножити на q в третій степені.
12 - це буде п’ятий член і т. д.
Тобто правильна відповідь це 6.
Давайте подивимось що сьогодні
на занятті ми з вами вивчали.
Сьогодні ми з вами практикувалися в
розв’язуванні задач, які пов’язані
з геометричною прогресією,
а саме формулою n-го члена.
Найбільше практика допомагає,
коли ви самі розв’язуєте,
тому краще візьміть підручник
і ще раз порозв’язуйте ці приклади.
Бувайте.
До побачення.